genius is the first scripted series on
magia the first season of genius is the
story of Albert Einstein which were
telling over the course of 10 episode we
all know of his genius his gifts but
Albert Einstein's private life is far
more complicated and dramatic and
certainly I agree and there's a very
human story to be told here what most
people know about Albert Einstein is
he's got crazy hair and they know equals
mc-squared but in fact Albert Einstein
was a fascinating character with a
fascinating personal life he was totally
dedicated to his work and he sort of
seemed to go through his life and his
family relationships like a bull in a
china shop he was someone who followed
his heart a lover of life but I don't
think he ever saw the damage there was
causing what this series attempts to do
is to tell the story of them and it
really shows him warts and all the
really extraordinary aspects of his life
and his work and also his flaws as a
human being I think the great thing
about the series is that it really looks
at he's used my image of him was as I'm
sure a lot of exist as everybody
man but I had no idea of the nature of
the beast he was as a young man so
there's quite a lot about his form of
years and domestic issues the number of
lovers lives from other tech people know
so much about we began thinking about
how we would tell the story of Albert
Einstein first it was Walter Isaacson's
fantastic book no a-pink's wonderful
screenplay for episode 1 and the idea of
taking this to National Geographic Nat
Geo channel was instantly interested and
really within a day or two we said this
could launch a series once now geo
decided they wanted to make the show of
course now there's this problem we see
that Einstein his entire life and we
knew for production reasons that it
would be very very difficult even if we
could find the perfect actor believably
play seventeen and sixty seven we
wouldn't be able to pull it off on a
television schedule and I suggested
early on that perhaps we should be
looking for two actresses to play
Einstein and Geoffrey Rush
instantly was at the top of our list of
candidates who could play Albert
Einstein from forty something on through
the end of his life
Geoffrey was actually quite interested
in this role but we had very big
problems with the timing because Ron had
a very tight schedule and Geoffrey had a
tight schedule so we ended up creating a
really crazily inefficient somewhat
nonsensical production schedule but it
ended up making the most sensible
because it allowed us to get
Jeffrey this is one of the great parts
and the scale of it is so big so Ron was
very excited by it and said let's do
this this would be great in the question
was well once we found out Jeffrey would
be interested who can refine can we
match him up with because that had to be
remarkable
we started pairing up photographs and
suddenly there was this photograph of
this guy I didn't know but who looked at
some of the bone structure and so forth
of Jeffrey Roger
his name is Johnny Flynn in normal life
I don't think you can find someone
that's less like Einstein so I was
confused when I got sent the part we
watched this young man audition and I
looked at Ron and I and he looked at me
and we both knew that this guy was so
much more interesting than any other
actor that we had seen for the role but
he has blond hair and blue eyes he looks
nothing like Albert Einstein and so with
our incredible hair makeup team we
pulled off this I think pretty
extraordinary transformation the one
foot Davina and Fay who Donald maker
worked in all these amazing kind of
prosthetic pieces and they liked my hair
obviously and thankfully got out of them
having a poem but they curl my hair they
use wigs for different ages and it's
amazing what they did and I think it
kind of works having this material to
really research is great and the entire
production office becomes kind of like a
giant classroom and everyone just
immerses themselves and then feels a
level of commitment to the subjects that
we're trying to depict absolutely
authentic City is very important in a
story like this because we are not
telling something fictional it's so it's
a true story it's about somebody who
really made a difference and someone
who's known all
the world costume Isis was really
exciting because the story starts in
1886 carries one into 1955 costume is
amazing and already those things you
know lifts you you literally put on the
costume and it really does so much for
you and it's incredibly authentic a lot
of research prevented to it and when I
had to make the costumes made sure you
know we got real fabrics which were pure
which would match the period you know we
did not use anything that was modern my
favorite thing is the fittings and
Milady's bows when I put on one of her
days I feel myself shifting into her
we've been very lucky being located in
Prague because the whole city's become
our back lot Prague is of course a city
that is very important in Einsteins life
pivotal in a lot of ways it's also a
great motion picture hub a place where
there's deep support both in front of
and behind the cameras what's great
about product is that it's a very much
essential European city so you can use
parts of the city to pass for
Switzerland or Germany and obviously for
Prague itself it's so beautiful it's the
sort of place you could come and just
walk around for days it's amazing how
many locations there are that are so
Christina
that's a pretty impressive setup here
every location we're using and so many
of the center are practical they're real
and it's just wonderful we've had
absolutely wonderful feedback from the
actors they've all seemed to respond
very much to the period detail in all of
the sense you light switches and power
sockets and what we can watch
pencil pen that we give them has been
very very carefully thought about and
all that attention to detail seems to be
paying off the idea very early on the
challenge for NatGeo
was we want to really bold cinematic
look we don't we don't want this to look
like a television show and of course we
had Ron Howard who is going to direct
this and there was no way that Ron was
going to do something that looked
conventional in the very first time I
spoke to her on about it there was a
strong emphasis on doing something that
does the the time period justice at the
same time that doesn't feel to appeared
piece dusty it was something really we
were very much intended to do something
that I still a very current feel to it
it's stunning it's amazing mattias our
director of photography is incredible he
works so quickly
the lighting is beautiful it works for
multiple angles the way it shot I just
think is so dynamic Ron found a very
energetic style a very youthful vibrant
energy
way to shoot this show so I think it
feels very modern and particularly when
we're with the young Einstein it feels
very youthful and sexy this is a great
moment to be able to tell the story of
Albert Einstein what he accomplished the
times delivery and having very ambitious
partners like National Geographic making
it possible to tell this story and a
much more cohesive and comprehensive way
and as a storyteller it's incredibly
exciting to be able to get at the
details the spirit the soul of this
amazing man
[Music]
you